all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you ready america
[Music]
a famous man once said you don't know
where you're going
unless you know where you're going
and that famous man
was me
so what we're going to do tonight is
tell you where jesse waters prime time's
going but before we do that let's talk
about where we are now
the american people have run out of
patience
and we're tired of being disrespected
ignorant greedy leaders sold out our
factories and pride to the chinese
communists for unpatriotic prophets
deployments in iraq and afghanistan wars
shamefully mismanaged took a physical
and mental toll
we were over saturated with highly
addictive painkillers while wall street
blew up the economy and escaped with
golden parachutes instead of prison
stripes
six cyber warriors divided us by race to
distract us from the real division class
as we erupted and tried to fix all this
a steady diet of hoaxes and hatred was
forced down our throats
the left romanticized rage and
resistance for four straight years but
now they want to cancel you for just
daring to disagree
and just as we came up for air a sketchy
virus slipped out of the very country we
arrogantly misjudged two decades ago
when we brought them into the wto
then they locked us down shuttered our
businesses and closed our schools well
they bought the dip and capitalized on
the new normal the permanent pandemic
power grab and after everything turns
out we were right from the very
beginning weren't we
am i being too dramatic
probably
but do i know what i'm talking about of
course i do
the american people have been
disrespected for far too long and that
stops tonight
we'll be exposing the scoundrels
celebrating the patriots and making sure
we're respected
whenever some snob or idiot disrespects
us we'll confront them and tell them
what's up
and they better start listening they
can't pretend like they don't hear us
anymore
the same goes for all the crooked
politicians out there we're in a
republic and we give our representatives
power to represent us not themselves
every night we'll remind them they work
for us
am i taking myself too seriously maybe
but we'll figure it out
bottom line the country's screaming out
listen to us and we will
here's one way how
as most of you know my mom's always
texting me to tell me how she feels but
that's not fair especially for me
because she's such a big lib
so we're going to try something new
i'm going to give out my phone number
so you can text me too
it'll always be right there at the
bottom of your screen
make sure to include your name city and
state if you're old-fashioned email
waters at fox.com remember name city and
state
jesse waters has always always been
about connecting with the people and
telling it straight in fact i did that
earlier right here in new york city
[Music]
new show launching jesse waters prime
time you excited yes i am have you ever
heard of jessie waters prime time no no
no i haven't do you know who jesse
waters is
no i'm waters
you jesse waters
[Laughter]
jesse waters prime time drops monday at
seven that's amazing i love seven
o'clock i'm pumped up i'm all good and
ready jesse what he's the man right here
oh god dude every time i see you it just
hurts my brain
oh the fact that you exist it's a damn
good thing he doesn't know how much i
hate his guts
what do you watch at seven o'clock right
now
bad woman i'm not gonna be wearing any
leather that's the point reality shows
news
well you're in luck
cause that's what i do okay what kind of
news do you watch
cnn fake news
cnn is fake news don't talk to me
on jesse waters primetime what news
topics do you want to see me cover
anything that's actually real time now
for some real news of the week safety in
new york and immigration the filibuster
world peace man what topics in the news
would you like to see me cover i got
older than the air and people don't like
that
you smell that what is that
what what's that smell oh me oh the
oatmeal
ominous variant did you get omicron yeah
did you yeah what were your symptoms i
haven't experienced any type of
symptoms thankfully i got um
pills are good
i'm very concerned about the casinos
because i don't want the graduates to go
and take their graduation money and go
to the casinos right away
rain man yeah let's play some fun which
guest would you like to see me have on
ron desantis judge jeanine kyle
rittenhouse kevin hart me i'll go on
pick me
choose me
love me should i interview aoc
yes interview her cause it's like
where's where is she in the city what is
she doing for the city she like she like
laughed it's like can you make me my
drink then cheers
should i interview joe biden sure why
not how is he doing
i would imagine he's going lovely you
have a great imagination
anyone you want to say hi to at fox
right now oh tucker carlson you chose to
wear a bow tie
oh my
god sean and especially tucker homer
simpson
any words of advice for me just keep on
rocking keep up to go work do you
remember who i am
um waters
waters john waters and this is my world
this is your world hi world can i pop
your bubble
oh
i love that yeah here you go
[Music]
so we'll keep connecting to the country
on the streets on tv and yeah you can
text me
prime time will represent the people and
respect the people for example we sent
producers to joe biden's hometown
scranton pennsylvania to ask if the
president has been true to his scranton
roots
let's just say he's not the hometown
hero the media told you he was
just know this we have a sense of
purpose and a sense of humor
no one says the news has to be boring
and i promise this show will not be
boring
so ride with prime time we'll take the
trip together
and not the kind of trip gutfeld is
thinking about but if that's your thing
fine
i have a good feeling where this is all
going
and you already know by this point i've
never been wrong
i'm also predicting aaron rodgers is
going to win mvp a championship no he's
going to win the super bowl
okay so maybe i was wrong once very rare
just don't tell me you don't feel what's
happening
something rising up from the bottom
parents have been activated while
workers have begun bargaining for a
better lifestyle
people voting with their feet fleeing
from blue to red states day traders and
social media stars making a fortune or a
name for themselves outside the confines
of corporate america hispanic americans
swerving into the republican party black
americans questioning the democrat
monopoly on their vote the rise of
independence all of us
sick of being manipulated for money
censored for political power and abused
bipartisan prosecutors
so stick with me for one reason because
i love you
this is a love story
and unlike biden i actually will
outperform expectations hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else